is Russell Wilson jr. the third with us
for sure is the part-time quarterback of
the Seahawks there hi Russ
I'm here I didn't know you had a
Mercedes AMG bang oh yeah yep I'm
killing it I roll big now yep I see you
I see you all right what's the first car
you ever man the first guy I've owned
let's see here the first car I ever
owned with a Jeep Cherokee a red Jeep
Cherokee stick shift 1998 I believe red
outside and and in Pam and the tan gray
cloth interior and NC State bought that
for you of course Wisconsin did my bet
okay are you done with your your summer
vacation there your Spring Fling with
the Yankees are you done it was amazing
just to be able to just you know I think
you said 127 you know World
Championships when you think about that
there's something to bat or something
make some special sauce to that riders
there's a Roma air and the reality is
that there's a commitment to excellence
it's just phenomenal you know I had the
chance to be around that every day and
just to be around obviously the great
players like Erin judge and Stanton
Sanchez and those guys and and the
gardener too as well and also you think
about eating about you know Reggie
Jackson being there and just to be able
to sit down and talk to him about you
know what it took for him to be mr.
October and just you know I mean they
still had the same bottles in the
training and the Mickey Mantle ball that
he's back in that day they still have
those thank you know that's just the
pride and tradition that they have and
so it was an amazing experience you know
I got to hit me up into the big boys
group with the BP group every day which
is amazing just watching those guys hit
550 footers and then and then I got
swinging away and then I had my born at
bad doctor let's knock out gimmi gimmi
you played in a couple of Super Bowls
and then you go to at bat in a spring
training game compare and contrast the
nerves of those two moments I was ready
to go man was like that much
94 in a way I took a hack at home listen
it out but sounded right straight back
but I was lazy too low and then they
need through Matt breaking breaking
football what six years yeah you know
but it was a lot of really honestly I
think - awesome
you know diving into the mental side of
things with the players and how I
prepare how they prepare the one pitch
mentality all that kind of stuff and
then and then and then also to just you
know meeting great friends and people
you know I think we were able to go out
to dinner you know I have a really
really good time at dinner a bunch of us
and just sit down and talk about the
highs and lows of lifes and sports and
everything else that we go through and
and it's just it's just great and I just
I just love sports in general so it was
an amazing experience you know once you
they say it an inside scoop on New York
Yankees is once you once you wear the
pin structure you're immortal you know
and so I had just just to be able to put
those pinstripes on just to be a part of
that was pretty cool
would you want to give it a full time go
you said what I wanted you say you know
well you know I love what I do now you
know I'm focused on winning you know you
know Super Bowls and doing and doing
that part of it and I think that you
know my obsession with winning is my
addiction the winning is is what I'm
really focused on and that this is the
only Anki thing is a part of that
there's only angry thing as a part of
Addison's that I get to be around
winning formula I think if you want to
be great you have to surround yourself
around greatness and and I think that's
you know a special thing for me so I
don't know I'm looking forward to the
season coming up hypothetically
hypothetically yeah you got another ring
with the the Seahawks three years down
the road wife says you know what we
gotta wait three years you can go now
how about your deals up in two years
oh yeah you can get it this next year
ring is there a scenario where you just
go you know what I like like Tebow is 30
Jordan was 30 when he tried what are you
29 yeah just turned 29
okay let's say you play football four
more years
you get one more ring that means you're
gonna be a Hall of Famer
you got your money you got your health
you got your wife you got your you know
family you could get baseball try I mean
you know what I think
you know I I'm hoping that we can find a
way to get a ring this year somehow and
and do all that work and then hopefully
the New York Yankees get a ring then on
the baseball ring are you getting a ring
do you get a ring if the Yankees joking
it was just one of plenty of things but
you know I look at baseball has always
been a major part of my life you know I
think like I said you know people always
don't talk about how I you know I get
away make those throws and you know from
the side or whatever and I just honestly
the baseball part of it for me you know
I growing up and and like I said the
mental aptitude that you gotta have in
baseball has got to be strong I'd be
focused and and I you know I honest I'd
use that I used that for the fourth
quarters I used that in the game and
this game the game's on the line and to
be able to stay calm we've got to stay
clear and be able to stay one throw one
pitch at a time that mentality really
really really really shows up I believe
I think you could do it I I think if you
would if you wanted to be a baseball
player you could have been a
professional baseball player well yeah
that's what they said to ejection was
telling me that so that was a you know
just I I'm in love with the game I love
I love plants what I played my whole
life since I was three years old we used
to play triple headers back in the day
you know when I was growing up so that's
I played more baseball in my whole life
than any other sport but you know like I
said I got a pretty good good good job
right now
he's Russel Wilson jr. the third the
Seahawks quarterback and spent a week
with the Yankees in spring training
wanted bat and struck out on a fastball
and you almost hit it I like how you
said you almost hit it out but you
fouled it back
well it's a baseball term but you swing
straight back you know you're on I was
on it now you play with some big guys in
the NFL but you're around
and judge you're gonna tight ends or
what position I'm gonna serve sure I
mean I think you know judge first of all
looks just like Jimmy Graham those guys
are gonna look like there could be twins
it could be brothers you know and so and
then used to I mean judges what six six
seven 275 you know you know is hitting
the ball 550 feet stand you know six six
you know maybe six five but looks like
he's six six and probably about 265 so
those guys because of super athletic and
and they train they train the right way
to I mean you can tell they're they're
they're top-notch athletes for sure give
me the NFL NBA player that you're
baseball player you'd like to see play
football you can give you the NBA player
how about baseball player because you'd
probably pick LeBron so let me ask you
the the baseball player you'd like to
see play football I would say judge
judge Mike Trout is pretty yeah have you
seen his highlight film from high school
I'm super athletic and we make him plays
all day he's probably the guy that I
would say you know so that would be cool
to have Jimmy Graham on one who's a
better baseball player you or Tebow I
have no idea I haven't seen people play
you know so you know and he plays
outfield so I'm more of a million solar
so you know I don't know what to see one
day maybe but if I look at baseball
I mean baseball is so humbling that I
mean we look at quarterbacking is the
toughest position in all the sports but
man when you go to the plate and if
you're three out of ten you're really
good I don't know like wouldn't it be
hard to deal with failing 70% of the
time well yeah you know you have the
Corvette mentality 340 know good so you
know I think that uh that's what makes
baseball so difficult people understand
you know how hard it is to hit a you
know you know 95 mile-per-hour
but I have a little bit of movement to
it or curveball going you know a 84
miles an hour
some guys 102 you know and so it's
really tough you know but you know you
enjoy the gaming you know that I'm
passionate about the game and stuff
that's the whole mental side of the
pauli do you have Russell's time for tee
time at the combine did you guys want to
take a guess
the official your 40-yard time at the
NFL cart
I'm Russell Wilson jr. the third man I'm
gonna say 4/6 Russ do you remember what
your aunt at the combine no I I think
they got my first time was four five I
believe and I think they and then I'm
not sure what I run the second time four
five five four five five okay so that
was my official time right so I was the
two x times combined or whatever yes how
do they do it what would you run now oh
no I'm betraying like crazy I think I'm
faster now honestly really um yeah I'm
faster now I'm more explosive you know
and so I don't know I'm more quick than
sighs no I think that's kind of part of
my game dude you how many times am I run
how many times am I really running
full-speed in the game not by me you
know but the you know the thing that I
try to do is just try to be quicker than
everybody else do you watch the Super
Bowl I did we were there
I mean Sierra were there we got to watch
it oh okay
who were you rooting for him look man I
was hoping to make a good game I think
that I first of all just he to see if he
falls by the way he did was pretty
exciting to these amazing season and we
can't looking in the same class together
and uh I just remember you know us doing
in the rookies symposiums and you know
all that kind of stuff together and just
what a class act he is and I've been
around him a bunch and just ease a
competitor and so he was just great to
see him by the way he did I mean I've
gotten no Tom you know over the past
couple years and you know he obviously
he was lights out the whole night you
know and so it was a great game honestly
I only team I'm rooting for the Seahawks
did you like my thought did you guys
stay for the trophy ceremony no we got
out of there quickly wait wait I was on
stage I was handing out the trophy I
know I know that's all I did I didn't
want to see your faces great but your
wife probably did
I mean don't cheat her I'm sure she did
yeah she loves you see she's like oh
you're going down a bad Patrick show
well we go way back before you even met
her so you tell her that I know I said a
lo and I hope she tells the family that
was great family is really amazing he
was just traveling he was in one I was
at the Yankee spring training I had a
chance to bring the kids with me so we
had a lot of fun doing that and and just
being around each other so it's good to
have some quality time with the kiddos
and have some fun while doing that too
so everybody's doing well a little baby
girl CNS she's now 10 months and maybe
future he's three and a half on his way
to four and they're like and you know
enjoying life and and having a lot of
fun and hanging out so he's great you
changing diapers oh yeah I actually
helped change one this morning who I
said no I said help change if I put the
NFL play clock on you could you change a
diaper before the play clock expires
42nd play clock yeah that is the correct
answer we've all had those tire blowouts
where you go uh-uh hon I need some help
in here we got it we got a spill in
Aisle 6 over here honey Pete Carroll's
calling can you change this diaper you
wouldn't answer this one yeah yeah hey
great to talk to you and I you know
maybe five years down the road you know
you might stay in spring training and
decide that you don't want to leave
right I think you might give it a
knowing you as competitive as you are
you you might want to give this a real
shot one day just saying
is for sure my turn no they are great to
talk to you enjoy the off season thanks
again
it's always a pleasure but are you
talking to you come on
that's a Russell Wilson jr. the third
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]